a possible serial killer of three people
has a neighborhood on high alert in
Tampa Florida they were shot dead in the
past two weeks
the victims were just a few blocks from
each other take a look at this
surveillance video it shows a man
walking in the area when one of the
three people was murdered so police want
the public to help identify him because
he may have information about the
killings
Omar Villafranca is in Tampa with the
investigators urgent search for
information Omar good morning good
morning Seminole Heights residents
walked this area last night to take back
the streets from a killer terrorizing
their neighborhood three people killed
in a 10-day period there's a memorial
that's been set up for the latest victim
a young man who just got off at the
wrong bus stop be afraid you know you
won't get away with it at a memorial for
20-year old Anthony Knight boa his
father Kasim R says Anthony was targeted
because he had autism
he never say nothing bad will mean night
Boyle was shot dead while walking in
Tampa Seminole Heights neighborhood
around 8 p.m. on Thursday 10 days
earlier just over 100 yards away 22 year
old Benjamin Mitchell was killed after
being shot at a bus stop about four days
later police found 32 year old Monica
hafez body in a vacant lot less than a
mile away investigators say she was
walking to meet a friend before being
shot we're doing everything we can to
catch this person so we can put an end
to this Tampa Police Chief Brian Dugan
believes the killings are connected
based on their close proximity and
timeframe but he's refraining from
labeling the unknown suspect as a serial
killer I'm very cautious with that term
because we don't have enough information
we don't know it could be multiple
people we wrote along with sergeant Eric
DeFelice one of the officers now
blanketing the area warning the
community to keep vigilant what are you
looking for we're looking for out of the
ordinary something that stands out that
would give us an indication that maybe
somebody's armed maybe somebody's acting
in a suspicious manner
police are desperate for any kind of
lead in this case now the FBI is helping
out the Tampa Police and they're
offering a $25,000 reward for any
information that leads them to a suspect
Charlie thanks Omar